My name is "Ji Chen"
Chief Executive of Ufoto
Since the company was founded in 2016
We have published many self-image applications
And participation across social networks in the global market.
Our first application, Sweet Selfie,
Million active users per day in less than 3 months
Highlighted on Google Play.
To date
The application has reached 300 million downloads worldwide.
Sweet Snap focuses on animated posters
And short videos with special effects.
So that users can record happy memories in a more vivid way
My name is Li Zeng, product manager at Ufoto
As our products focus on the global market
The set properties of self-images that include
Beauty features, filters, collages, photo booth, frames and wallpapers
Require that appropriate regionalization becomes a key to achieving a high and sustainable retention rate.
For example, in India
The crucifixes and pictures combined with the Holly Red Festival powder throw effects provided us with the ingredients
Which allows users to celebrate the festival directly in the application.
We use Firebase Remote Config to implement an effective operating strategy
We use the A / B test
To check the design method
Now self-portrait assets are downloaded more than a million times a day
And use it more than 5 million times a day.
The share of self-image assets increased by 100%.
Challenge in emerging markets such as India, Brazil and Mexico
Is to deal with specifications
Different devices and network connection.
We use multiple APK packages
To deploy different apk packages, each is routed to various settings.
We have also developed various image processing algorithms
For various hardware specifications.
Thanks to Android Go, we can provide
Improved experience on cheap phones.
We removed unnecessary dynamic libraries in the application
It was set to download smaller assets
When it runs on a screen and a smaller storage space.
To optimize performance, we dynamically allocate the cache
Depending on the available memory size.
If memory is low, a stronger reuse strategy will be used.
Application size is 25% smaller on Android Go
It uses 20% less memory.
After setting up our apps to work on Android Go
Active Sweet Snap users increased by 465% daily.
Self-portraits symbolize a life full of optimism.
These are self-portraits of smiling people
Is what drives us to move forward.
Google Play provides us with a global arena
By allowing us to entertain Android users in different countries.
We will continue trying to discover
New ways to take self-portraits
And help users around the world
To record special moments in their lives.